l'ouverture des frontières aux états
unis donc pour les touristes vacciner
alors qu'à l'intérieur du pays la
politique sanitaire est contestée dans
certains états une cour d'appel fédérale
a suspendu ce week-end l'obligation
vaccinale dans les entreprises une
mesure voulue par le gouvernement byden
c'est donc un nouveau revers pour le
président américain pour en parler on
retrouve notre correspondant à
washington thomas bonnet bonsoir
surpoids composent cette décision de
suspendre cette mesure défendue par le
président
c'est une décision d'une cour d'appel
fédéral de la nouvelle orléans les juges
estiment qu'il y a des arguments
laissant croire qu'il y a de sérieux
problèmes constitutionnels et
procéduraux concernant donc la mesure
gouvernementale annoncée la semaine
dernière par joe biden une plainte avait
été déposée dans la foulée notamment par
des représentants républicains parmi eux
le procureur général de louisiane ou
encore le gouverneur républicain de
l'état du texas a tous deux se sont
félicités de la suspension de la mesure
annoncée par joe biden écouter
alertait la cour d'appel fédérale vient
de suspendre temporairement le mandat du
vaccin de baden des audiences d'urgence
auront lieu prochainement nous aurons
notre journée devant les tribunaux pour
annuler l'abus d'autorité
inconstitutionnel de baden l'action de
la cour empêche non seulement byden
d'aller de l'avant avec son ex est
illégal mais commande également l'examen
judicieuse que nous avons demandé byden
n'imposera pas de procédures médicales
au peuple américain sont les freins et
contrepoids prévu par notre constitution
cette mesure d' obligation vaccinale
annoncé par joe biden était la dernière
étape en date pour tenter d'accélérer la
campagne de vaccination aux etats unis
une obligation de vaccination pour des
millions d'employés dans le pays pour
tous ceux qui travaillent dans des
entreprises qui emploient de plus plus
de 100 ha salariés avec toutefois la
possibilité pour ceux qui refuseraient
de se faire vacciner de se faire tester
régulièrement alors les autorités
américaines estiment aujourd'hui
qu'elles vont défendre cette mesure
devant la justice et elles se disent
confiante sur l'avenir légal de ce
dispositif écouté par exemple les
détails donnés il ya quelques instants à
peine par la porte parole de la maison
blanche
le ministère du travail a la
responsabilité de garantir la sécurité
des travailleurs et dispose de
l'autorité légale pour le faire le
ministère du travail détermine les
travailleurs à risque où confronté à ce
qu'on appelle un grave danger et si vous
regardez autour de vous et si nous
faisons le bilan de ces dernières années
plus de 750 mille personnes sont mortes
du code vide aujourd'hui il y a environ
1300 personnes par jour qui continue
d'en mourir si ce n'est pas un grave
danger je ne sais pas ce que c'est
pour le dire simplement il s'agit
d'assurer la sécurité des personnes sur
leur lieu de travail et il est crucial
est important de le faire et c'est le
message que nous voulons faire passer
la maison blanche estime qu'il y a
urgence à augmenter le nombre de
vaccinés aux états unis elle se sert
aussi des exemples d'entreprises
américaines qui ont mis en place des
dispositifs d'obligations de vaccination
la maison blanche explique que dans ces
entreprises le nombre de vaccinés a
grimpé en flèche mais vous avez aussi
des personnes qui s'opposent à cette
obligation de vaccination qui explique
qu'il ya des problèmes d'effectif dans
un certain nombre d'entreprises qui ont
justement mis en place ces obligations
de vaccination on peut rappeler
notamment le cas de cette
compagnie aérienne southwest airlines
qui avait dû annuler des milliers de
vols par manque justement d'effectifs
même si on sait que la direction de
cette compagnie aérienne a toujours nié
tout lien entre ces problèmes
d'effectifs et la mise en place d'
obligation vaccinale